framed by the shattered glass of his
famous restaurant
this is uriburi and in a country
consumed by hatred and anger his
is a face of hope
a few days ago the communal violence
that exploded here reached his door
his restaurant set ablaze by
arab-israeli attackers
this was on fire the fire was just this
was already broken
and the fire went out here like sky high
but here's the thing standing in the
burnt out shell of the place he
cherishes
yuri feels no anger and no desire for
retribution
you don't feel hatred or bitterness
towards these people
and i
i try to ignore
and not to reach a point of feeling
hatred
because it doesn't lead to anything that
is positive
i have not no intention to take revenge
i think that the police has to do their
job
this is one of the dining rooms for 35
years he's been cooking here for all
comers
of all faiths it didn't matter to him
and it didn't matter to them
arab israelis and jewish israelis
who have come here for so long will come
and eat here again in your view will
they
they look out these are all a mixture
of arabs and jews while we were there
gathering outside
chefs restaurant owners customers jews
muslims and christians together
here to sign a pledge to reject division
and embrace peace
we have to take care to reach the
highest standard
of call of coexistence otherwise
uh in just in order to to
you know guarantee the the future of uh
all of us you know and give a better
future to the
our children and grandchildren then it
was time to head through the ancient
streets of this historic city
where he has many friends
to where else but a restaurant an arabic
one
a place to eat and a place to heal